chez mon bon jour en jour merci de nous
accueillir chez vous vous êtes chez vous
fait plaisir dans l'édifice jacques
parizeau de la caisse de dépôt
vous allez présenter les résultats
financiers aujourd'hui 10 4% résultats
solides mais quand même sous les indices
de référence
ce que ça vous déçoit comment vous
percevez ça mais je veux dire nous quand
on regarde le rendement de 10 points 4 %
de cette année ses 31 milliards quand
même de rendement emplacement qui ont
été créés pour les québécois s'était mis
en valeur absolue de dollars c'est la
meilleure performance qu'on n'ait jamais
eu et le 10.4 en pourcentage la
meilleure performance des cinq dernières
années donc ça c'est la toile de fond
quand je regarde ensuite ce 10 points 4
% la bonne coupe de choses il est plus
élevé que notre performance moyenne sur
cinq ans sur dix est également et
surtout parce que c'est le monde qu'on a
des déposants donc c'est ma
responsabilité en tant que prise d'un
chef de la direction de la caisse sa
rencontre les besoins de nos dépose à
peu près une points 5 fois les besoins
en eau des pauses qui sont environ en
moyenne de 6%
donc de ce point de vue là je suis
content de cette performance mais en
même temps quand on regarde la bourse
puis je sais que vous avez pas juste des
actions la moitié de votre portefeuille
sont des actions mai à new york ont eu
31 32 pour cent à toronto 22 23 pour sas
qu'on se serait pas attendue à des
résultats quand même plus de vie à la
caisse cette année première chose vous
le mentionnez des marchés boursiers en
hausse de 25 parfois même plus de 30%
ouais la quatrième plus forte
progression des trente dernières années
sociale ne pas oublier et quand on
regarde tout ça moi ce qu'ils appellent
un peu à la prudence je crois qu'on
apprend seulement tout investi
en action dans les marchés boursiers
c'est qu'en réalité l'investisseur cette
année en 2009 10 je suis prêt à payer
30% plus cher pour la même chose
pourquoi le marché boursier est monté de
30 pour ça il ya aucune croissance des
profits des entreprises donc je fais
juste dire attention on se doit d'être
là on est un rendement d'un indice
marchés boursiers de 18%
la caisse a fait 17 points 2 alors moi
de ne pas voir le dernier point 8 1%
dans un marché où est-ce que c'est tout
cela est un peu questionnable semble
déconnectée de l'économie réelle jeudi
c'est tout à fait dans le sens de la
stratégie qu'on recherche c'est leur
premier vol
ce que je veux dire c'est que se
contente de livrer au dépose ses des
rendements plus fiable plus stable être
moins exposé est moins vulnérable pour
offrir des rendements qui sont tous à
l'intérieur d'un corridor qui rassure
nos déposants d'une année à l'autre
allez vous accélérer du côté de
l'énergie aussi vous dit qu'à
l'exception de l'énergie qui s'est
replié sur la période tous les secteurs
fournit son apport positif sur cinq ans
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas aller plus
loin que la baisse d'intensité de votre
portefeuille puis amorcer un
désinvestissement dans les énergies
fossiles
payez déjà commencer je tiens à le dire
depuis quelques années ce seront se pose
toujours la question le rythme on peut
tu le faire plus vite le danger qu'on
est là dans ce que je disais parfois on
diminue notre position dans les
hydrocarbures
cette année ça a monté alors vous savez
en dollars on a beau baisser
il ya un autre effet contraire ou est ce
que les valeurs des fois dans certains
secteurs d'énergie comme cette année ont
remonté mais la direction qu'on ne crie
ya quelques années qui on va aller ça ne
changera pas je suis aussi le faire de
façon progressive de façon intelligente
les québécois parce que cette transition
lola
qui nous vaut de l'énergie va
s'effectuer sur plusieurs années dans le
monde réel
je me dois de le faire pas non plus que
ça coûte trop cher aux déposants c'est
constant on va continuer à le faire il
ya aucune question là dessus mais on se
doit de le faire progressivement pour
pas faire mal à nos deux posent depuis
1850 à chaque décennie et au moins une
récession aux états unis sauf la
dernière décennie exactement était clair
pour vous comme pdg de la caisse en tout
cas pensez vous que vous avez des grands
risque de connaître une récession
on sait jamais c'est quand je dis pas
que c'est non plus même cette année mais
c'est plus une question de 30 questions
de 6 une question d'être de mon point de
vue à moi
c'est certain qu'on regarde quand elle
arrivera ces caisses qui voit la
déclencher c'est la première chose
cette année par exemple les tensions
commerciales serait peut être
l'événement qui aurait pu nous plonger
si la chine et les états unis avaient pu
garder la tête froide que bon prenons
une pause peut-être partie remise
c'était le facteur principal qui aurait
pu nous jeter peut-être dans une
certaine récession c'est plus là on
prend pas de deux semaines de polokwane
au virus par la suite arriver là je dis
ça peut être quand même quelque chose
d'important s'est conclue dans la chine
vous savez la chine devrait dix fois
plus intégrée dans l'économie mondiale
que lorsque le le strass est arrivé le
maintenant plusieurs années on fait
simplement dire que il va probablement
avoir un ralentissement m'emmener chez
pas de quel ordre ça pourrais je dis pas
que c'est la crise de 2008 mais en même
temps on n'est pas positionné de la même
façon si ça arrive les banques centrales
j'apprends généralement 4 à 5% de baisse
de taux pour se sortir d'une récession
on ne va pas connaître de nouveau parce
qu'on a connu en 2008 à la caisse de
dépôt bien sûr toujours c'est toujours
possible dans l'instance qu'une des
marchés subissent une régression
importante et la caisse n'est plus la
même de ce qu'elle était je pense que
notre niveau driss toutes les mesures
ont été pires dans la gouvernance
on a fait des tests extrêmement code de
scénario est ce qu'on subirait un
environnement macroéconomique comme ça
mais la caisse n'est plus au même
endroit qu'en 2000
dernier point est ce qu'on est mieux
avec 18% d'alstom qu'avec 32 5% de
bombardier transport qui vous rapporter
15 % de rendement par année écoutez
c'est une excellente question parce que
c'est l'investissement le plus important
l'histoire de la caisse donc on le fait
en toute connaissance de cause avec
lucidité
vous amenez un bon point on est dans une
société qui va devenir le leader mondial
hors chine d'un secteur extrêmement
prometteur avec des tendances lourdes
vont dans le sens de nos valeurs dans le
cadre de notre stratégie avec tout
l'urbanisation les changements
climatiques
c'est un joueur alstom si vous regardez
insuffisant depuis cinq ans vous
regardez leur performance c'est
extraordinaire comme performance est
stable c'est constant ils font des
cash-flows monétaire ils ont des bonnes
marges qui sont en hausse les revenus
sont en hausse
donc on se retrouve dans un
investissement chez bombardier transport
on avait de la conviction dans ce
secteur la met dedans entreprises qui
contenait encore plus forte
donc moi je me sens bien avec sont
investis allez vous demander 25 % de
contenu québécois dans les projets de
mobilité durable puisque maintenant vous
allez tu actionnaires donc d'alstom avec
deux sièges au conseil d'administration
mais je pense qu'on a une voix justement
le but d'avoir des investissements
importants comme ça on va être
l'actionnaire le plus important ça nous
donne voix au chapitre autour de la
table du conseil d'administration comme
on l'a fait dans cette transaction là on
sera toujours là prêt c'est de faire en
sorte que le québec ressort mieux
positionné à la suite de cette
transaction l'eau donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on va vraiment avoir comme
vigile et je pense que des bonnes choses
qui vont sortir parce qu alstom il
motivé parce que le québec peut apporter
dans cette transaction nous merci
monsieur les mots merci à vous merci
beaucoup à bientôt
merci